All right, let's get into audience questions
and at least one of them is really funny this
week. Hey David, you famously held Tesla stock
for a long time. Do you regret selling half
of your Tesla stock since it just went crazy?
Yeah. Earlier this year,
this week someone had told me that, uh, I
think it was during the Iowa caucus livestream
that day. Tesla's stock closed at seven 80
and as many of you know, I invested in Tesla
when the shares were um, right around $200.
And then I panicked, sold half of it when
Joe Rogan had Elon Musk on and Elon Musk smoked
pot, which I don't care about personally,
but the board went crazy and it looked like
it was trouble for Tesla. I panicked, sold
half of my stock and I say before, I don't
know what I'm doing with stocks. This is why
I really don't invest in individual stocks.
I only have I think six individual stocks
and otherwise almost all my money is in a
mutual funds and bonds because I just don't
know what I'm doing. I don't know. I, I do
things like panic sell. So do regret that
I sold half of the Tesla stock and since then
it must've been at about three 60 when I sold
half of it.
And now it's, you know, w it got close to
$800 per share during this week. Yeah. I mean
to some degree I regret it, but at the same
time I know going in individual stocks for
me are like gambling in that I don't know
when to buy. I don't know when to sell. I'm
too busy with other things to really be picking
stocks. So the amount of regret is relatively
small. I also, I didn't invest so much that
if I had held all of it right now, my financial
situation would be drastically different.
And by the way, the things I took it out of
when I sold that half, I put it into other
stocks that have done not as well, but also
well. So I'm, I don't live in the past to
the extent that I can avoid it. Um, I have
mild regret, but I think the, the lesson here
is whatever made me buy the Tesla stock to
begin with years ago when it was at like one
90 or 200 a share that didn't fundamentally
change when Elon Musk smoked pot with Joe
Rogan threatened to take the company private
at four 20 a share to Saudi buyers or something
like that, even though that was a violation,
I guess, of SCC law.
But Hey, you know, I mean, listen, we're,
we're starting to get nitpicky or you know,
whatever else that didn't change the promise
of the company. And now this is one of the
most valuable car companies in history. And
that's really what I should have focused on
in the same way that my mutual fund strategy
is, you just buy and hold. Because I guess
I believe in the future of the world economy
when I diversify across, you know, total international
stock market index, I'm basically taking a
bet on, I believe in the future of the world
economy. And if, uh, it goes away because
the climate implodes and we have no more planet,
I probably won't care that much about my mutual
funds because we'll all be dead or whatever.
In the same way, whatever made me think this
is a good investment for the longterm.
It didn't have to do with whether or not Elon
Musk was smoking pot with Joe Rogan. So in
retrospect, I should've just gone with the
initial reason I invested in Tesla, which
I thought, uh, I believe that it was a car
company that would become, uh, a, uh, a successful
staple in electric cars. That has happened.
I think 80 or 90% of electric cars on the
road today in the U S are Tesla. Um, and I
should not have panic sold. I regret it, but
I'm not living with my regret is the way I
would answer the question